so jeremiah making his 18th
start of the year looking for his eighth
victory
and let's see you later yeah tilly
carlson was leaving before
edward moscoso officially punched him
out so so if max kosovo had any doubt he
said well the guy's leaving i might as
well call this a strike
go ahead and throw that strike that
knuckle curve right out of the hand on
the subaru super mow
swag
[Applause]
that was a marvelous first in two
strikeouts and a 6-3
what are we going to get brad well it's
been a bit of a mixed bag this year
hasn't it dan when it comes to carlos
martinez the good
has been good the bad has been very bad
but we'll find out we're gonna find out
quick
when it comes to carlos martinez how
quick is he working
is he able to repeat his delivery is he
missing arm's side
how quickly does he make adjustments if
he is like these are all things when
carlos is on
you know pretty darn quickly
nice ovation for trevor story who
had the shot last night in the seventh
inning
the difference in the three to two win
oh
center field indeed this one's gone
one nothing colorado the harbor of day
will keep the doctor away
that's his sixth home run in the last 12
ball games
for trav it's uh
trying to sink the fastball it was the
inner third
and poi does it get everything behind
that classic swing on the subaru
superman
and again there's some boehner looking
up
that's the eighth home run carlos
martinez has given up four to a righty
four to 11.
harrison bader with a runner at first
and one down
vader deep left it's at the wall
it is gone it's a home run
his second in the series grand slam
two nights ago this one a two-run shot
and the cardinals go on top in this
independence day
cardinals with a couple of lineup tweaks
today it's matt carpenter batting fourth
harrison moves to six and he gets that
knuckle curve here
from marquez and deposits this thing
stays on it really well
it backs up a little bit he's ready
perfect balance swing
and there are the fireworks that we're
talking about dan those are them right
there getting something
some energy early in this ball game
ground ball arenado how about a turn
there it is in a double play 5-4-3
[Applause]
it's tough when your cousin starts a
double play on you
ouch we'll talk about that again
golden grounded out sharply to trevor
story his first time
two on one out nolan strikes out for the
second out of the end
[Applause]
two on two outs two and two on carpenter
and another strikeout
a little traffic he strikes out aronado
and carpenter he's got
six in three innings cards lead though
two to one
one two pitch
[Music]
left center right it'll be in right
uh oh and now the medical team out to
look at carlos martinez with mike maddox
maybe kisner saw something here adam
olsen they're looking at the
fingers in the hand it looks like he's
focusing on his grip so you wonder about
the forearm
in watching the pitch there wasn't
anything specific that looked like it
grabbed necessarily but it was a pitch
where
the hand and the arm dropped
o2 is right there nope yeah it is
it i was waiting for edwin moscoso he
took a little
more time before he raised his right arm
it sure looked like it was gonna be a
strike and that's strikeout number seven
for earmung
that's a strikeout according to angel
hernandez
carlson offered at it strikeout number
eight
for goldschmidt off three-two
with a secondary pitch strikes out or
not for the second time of the game
well there it is again and that's a
strikeout and
for the first time this year herman's
had double figures
in strikeouts that is number 10.
edmond with a base hit into center
[Applause]
pitch number 94 runner going for
the back
[Applause]
that was real close 16 stolen base now
for edmond 42
for the cardinals he got the strike out
of bader that was big
just the quickness
of edmond going in feet first keep that
tag on
2-2 and this is lifted to
shallow center bad read by bader he's
going to play
[Applause]
you hadn't had much action going on just
just create
something it was a well there it is
he lays it down no one comes and gets it
now he got topia a third with just one
out
gallegos with the pitch trevor hits it
in the air to left field it's going to
be
deep enough on the warning track carlson
grabs it
tapia tags he scores standing up
trevor's story with a long sacrifice fly
ties the game at two here in the eighth
that's the start
that'll bring up the hero for thursday
night second and back for elise
diaz winning run to second base hit left
field
hope for the baseball's carlson here's
the three front day